let's say that we have the equation
two-fifths
x
is equal to ten
how would you go about solving that
well you might be thinking to yourself
it would be nice if we just had an x on
the left-hand side instead of a
two-fifths x or if the coefficient on
the x were one instead of a two-fifths
and the way that we might do that is if
we were to multiply both sides of this
equation by five-halves
why five-halves
well five halves if you notice when i
multiply five halves times two-fifths
it's going to get us to one five times
two is ten two times five is ten so it's
going to be ten over ten or one or you
could think about five divided by five
is one two divided by two is one
and you might say is that magical how
did you think of five halves well five
halves is just the reciprocal of
two-fifths i just swapped the numerator
and the denominator to get five-halves
and then why did i multiply it times the
right hand side well anything i do to
the left hand i also want to do to the
right hand so the left hand side
simplifies to this is all one so it's
just going to be x
is equal to or we could say 1x is equal
to 10 times 5 halves that's the same
thing as 50 halves i could write it this
way 50 over 2 which is the same thing as
25. let's do another example
let's say we have the equation 14 is
equal to seven thirds b
see if you can solve this
well once again it would be nice if the
coefficient on the b weren't a seven
thirds but instead we're just one if you
just said b
is equal to something well we know how
to do that we can multiply both sides of
this equation times the reciprocal of
the coefficient on b times the
reciprocal of seven thirds what's the
reciprocal of seven 3
well the denominator will become the
numerator the numerator becomes the
denominator it's going to be 3
7. now of course i can't just do it on
one side i have to do it on both sides
so on the right hand side of this
equation 3 divided by 3 is 1. 7 divided
by 7 is 1. those all cancel out to 1. so
you're just left with 1b or just a b
and 13 or 3 7 times 14
you might see this as 14 over 1
and you could say okay this is going to
be 3 times 14 over
7 times 1
or you could say hey let's divide both a
numerator and a denominator by 7. so
this could be 2 and this could be one so
you're left with three times two over
one times one which is just going to be
equal to six
let's do another example
let's say
that we had
one
sixth a
is equal to two thirds
how could we think about solving for a
well once again it would be nice if this
one-sixths were to become a one and we
could do that by multiplying by six six
sixths is the same thing as one and to
make it clear that this is the
reciprocal we could just write six
wholes as six
ones or six wholes
when you multiply these this is all
going to be equal to one so you're left
with one a on the left hand side but of
course you can't just do it on the left
hand side you have to also do it on the
right hand side so a is going to be
equal to
over here we could say 2 times 6 over 3
times 1 so that would be 12 thirds
or we could say look 6 and 3 are both
divisible by 3 so 6 divided by 3 is 2 3
divided by 3 is one two times two is
four over one times one so it's going to
be four wholes or just four and we're
done